now ever since mankind invented the
wheel there have been some amazing
inventions that have totally changed our
lives for the better so in 1450 when
Jonas Gutenberg invented the world's
first printing press this helped spread
literacy and education throughout Europe
and in turn the rest of the world so
impactful isn't it Carl Benson 1885
developed the world's first automobile
which was powered by the internal
combustion engine and this helped in
increasing the mobility of mankind and
there are cars everywhere you see
nowadays in 1903 the Wright brothers
developed the world's first successful
self-propelled sustained flight and that
enabled us to send people and products
across the globe in a very short time
and in finally in 1876 Alexander Graham
Bell invented the telephone that helped
spread communication across wide areas
for the world now guys if there are more
such game changing inventions that you
can think of comment down below and
subscribe to our Channel